brother Ned Trump unleashing on
Democrats impeachment inquiry ahead of
next week's public hearings the
president facing off with the media and
covering a wide range of topics going
after the entire process the
whistleblower and much more the whole
thing is a scam it's this scam by the
Democrats to try and win an election
they shouldn't be having public hearings
is a hoax this is just like the Russian
witch-hunt these democrats are corrupt
nancy pelosi is the corrupt politician
when i released that call all of a
sudden everybody disappeared the
whistleblower is a disgrace to our
country his lawyer who said the worst
things possible
two years ago he should be sued and made
me for treason adam schiff is a corrupt
politician that's not giving us due
process not giving us lawyers at this
fight all that we're kicking their ass
adam jim is under heavy criticism from
GOP lawmakers they're accusing the intel
chair of limiting the witnesses that
they can call every one of the witnesses
that we put forward are going to be
substantive and it's going to lead back
to the corruption of the democrats and
what they were doing in Ukraine not to
mention whatever this whistle blow
whoever this whistle blower is and
whoever he's connected to we will be
trying to ask those questions and I
think if they don't give us several
witnesses I don't see how this is going
to have any credibility all right Jessie
weird I don't know where do you want to
begin I'll tell you at the B block the
Democrats to make impeachment boring
this was about a transcript of a phone
call with a country no one cares about
these are about transcripts from a
deposition that we can't even watch on
television and what are the transcripts
say it's from the Undersecretary of
Affairs for energy policy at the EU
these aren't household names they aren't
heavy hitters wake me up when the big
dogs testify in public the other thing
is no one can find Ukraine on a map if
you ask the American people anything
about Ukraine they don't know a thing
about it America
care about a few countries they care
about Saudi Arabia they care about
Israel they care about Russia China and
Mexico that's it
Ukraine doesn't rise to the level of a
country that people care about we're
talking about a military aid package to
a country that I guess needs help but a
lot of people don't really care that
much about if you turn on television you
see a reporter standing in Congress
saying someone was hearing something
from someone else who was concerned
about a military aid package it's
absolutely not registering and the
American people's brain because it's not
a sexy scandal Russia was sexy there was
intrigue people had handcuffs on him it
was about an election this has no
intrigue whatsoever and the Democrats
have failed to deliver any sort of
convincing thereof now the Republicans
they can start hammering people when it
becomes public maybe that's interesting
when you can watch something on
television right now it's a faceless
whistleblower the only thing that I was
concerned about all week about this
story are the new memos that came out
that showed when the prosecutor in
Ukraine raided burries mosz offices and
started confiscating all the
Lamborghinis from the owner that they
hired a bunch of lobbyists that met with
Kerry
they met with by these people and say
hey guys can you stop the corruption
prosecution and then Biden goes out on
tape and brags about stopping the
corruption prosecution that's
interesting to me the other stuff and I
would love to check your phone to see if
mom has texted what about Oh Canada you
don't care about Canada pay attention to
campus like Mexico Gallegos definitely a
hot country okay did you want to say
anything else listen when I was watching
the prison I was thinking to myself boy
this is to me a prime example of moving
the ball because all along they said we
want an official inquiry how a vote and
then you have your public hearings why
are you having all these hearings in the
dark well okay
let's have it and he says now hey they
shouldn't be having public hearings and
I think to myself what's going on I
think it's this is like moving the ball
moving the goal line it's Trump you want
to move the ball if you want to win yeah
but you want to move the goal line when
the other team is approaching the win
it's so disjointed Dana but I think it's
it's a tell that they at least the
presence very worried and they don't
have a Dana Perino in the White House on
messaging but they don't need me they
have him he is what I'm telling he
doesn't have a coherent message it's one
minute it's Schiff is a bad politician
Pelosi is a bad politician the whistle
blowers the issue Jessi referred to the
transcript said oh no I'm now he says
I'm gonna put out I actually think it's
working yeah I don't think they don't
need anybody else because he's willing
to go out there and do it I'm not gonna
lie it's Friday I've already checked out
Greatest Hits
I happen to think that what you're
saying is right he's his own
spokesperson and there's nothing like it
when he's out in front of that
helicopter it's almost impossible for
anybody to change the message that he's
pushing right and he's pushing it pretty
I think it's more coherent and then one
might want to believe but here's how
this artificial impeachment was set up
three years ago
you see tweets vowing impeachment would
happen you have a tweet admitting that
CNN's gonna help then shift coordinates
with the whistleblower who was a
basically a democratic Democrat
operative and now you now you have him
saying well Republicans they have to
justify the relevance of their witnesses
so he used in those tweets the word COO
twice and I remember very thoughtful
people saying you can't use the word COO
on television no no no no no no it'll
take you seriously if you say COO
they're actually admitting it's a coup
so I'm kidding I want to get from the
thoughtful conservatives can I finally
say coup now that it's a coup also
here's the other thing people are still
obsessed obsessed in the media with what
ifs as opposed to what ours it's my
greatest hit trump is it's not above the
law but he's also not beneath the law he
should not be punished for things that
he might be predicted to do by people
who hate you
right imagine if Joy Behar could decide
our fate right she could
say the five is going to do this and the
five is going to do that and we should
investigate him that's what's happening
to him right now his fate is being
decided by people hypothesizing is that
a word yes yes thank you hypothesizing
what he might do which he hasn't done
and it's done by people who were
terrible at predicting things none of
what these what-if errs I just coined
that what if what if these what if errs
protect predicted no there's been no
wars there's been no stock market crash
there's a 25th amendment 25th amendment
there's nothing if they if this what if
errs protect predicted the Sun coming
out tomorrow the Sun would explode and a
fiery but it's a fiery ball Webster's
will add what if first before a hearing
like this as you can imagine all the
lawyers all the staff that works for the
congressional leadership and all the
lawyers who work for the now people that
had to get a lawyer because now there
you have to go testify in front of them
what are they gonna do this weekend to
really see if they can make it not
boring as Jesse looks suggesting
hopefully they will be doing as much
research and thorough preparation as
possible on both sides anticipating the
questions I think it's really telling
and kind of humorous but the attorney
for the whistleblower who sent that
cease and desist letter to the White
House how he literally was like I mean
it was like theatrical anyone who is
complicit in this vindictive campaign
action or inaction morally and legally
responsible I mean I feel like he would
give anything to be the whistleblower
himself but I also think that the
trailer for next week was the Cavanaugh
hearings for the Democrats in that their
pattern is they're totally stoked for
the opportunity to grandstand and say
next week's going to be lit but really
we're just going to hear the same things
that already occurred in private
testimony that was leaked out with no
bombshells
even though they were telling us there
were bombs I don't think of anybody in
recent congressional testimony that has
enhanced their reputation with Oliver
North I was going to say in recent
history
that's what
we're in our 70s how come you didn't
pick up on Emily sing lip because that's
just like hip language that's very good
Jesse that is dramatic it's going to be
lit that's next
they need some drama for sure